this is common sense we teach you deep
ideas like living on less than you make
the concept Congress can't grasp getting
out of debt we don't have any payments
you've a lot of peace in your life you
know what else you have money
there's otherwise you're sending it all
of the stupid bank you save money for
emergencies first you need to grandma's
rainy day fund because it is gonna rain
grandma knew that you need to save and
invest for your kids college in your
retirement and you need to just plain
old build wealth you need to be
outrageously generous for those of us
that are evangelical Christians the
baseline starting point of that is your
tithe at your local church beyond that
though you catch somebody parking your
car and you give them a nice tip I
pulled up the other day in front of a
nice restaurant and this guy in a
freaking $100,000 Range Rover it gives a
guy five dollars to park his car you
mean there's just something wrong with
that transaction in my mind here's the
keys to my hundred thousand dollar
vehicle and here's five dollars to say
thank you I just don't I mean I Drive a
nice car so I give them $20 you know
what the weird thing is car sitting
right there when I come out it's the
most amazing thing yeah and you know but
those guys are out there in the heat and
the cold and rain those gals I mean
they're running up and down and I'm
gonna run up and down that's why I got
them there that's somebody waiting your
table how long has been since you
carried a hundred pounds where the dirty
dishes on a tray over your head gotta
give you a back ache about doing it all
day
thank you just don't leave somebody at
tip that's giving by the way in case you
didn't know I don't know there I'll shut
up you tightwad and you wonder why
you're broke cuz you're tight
I'll be outrageously generous it's a
sign of people who are winning with
money generous people are highly
attractive people everybody wants to be
around not because they want their money
but just because they're people that
smile never notice that selfish people
never smile they look like they were
weaned on a pickle
outrageous generosity and gratitude
contentment staying out of debt living
on less than you make saving money for
emergencies and to change your family
tree these are the hallmarks of people
who win with money they're the ones that
are on a plan the dreaded B word a
budget if you worked for a company
called you incorporated and your job was
to manage money for you incorporated and
you managed money for you incorporated
the way you manage money for you now
would you fire you if the answer is yes
please don't pray and ask God for more
money because you just self confess that
you're incompetent
if you would fire you what do you think
your Heavenly Father's gonna do he's
gonna look at you and going you are not
ready my son my daughter you are a fool
I'm gonna give you money make you a big
fool because when you get money you're
getting more to be more of what you
already are have you noticed that if
you're mean and you get money you're
really mean you don't meet those people
I've met them you mean somebody who's a
big giver there they love their generous
they're compassionate people that got
big heart they get money you know what
happens they become a philanthropist
they give Oh looking for opportunities
to give they found the secret to money
those people did yeah they understand
how it really works you get to be more
of what you are as you get money so you
probably need to decide what you are in
the process but be managing the money
well be diligent the diligent prosper
I read the parable the talents those
that are faithful with the little things
will be given more to manage they ever
heard that yeah you've heard that your
whole life most of you then be faithful
with
the little things faithful with what you
got yeah when you're sloppy with your
four dollars don't think you're gonna
get eight dollars this is not a hard
formula this is the stuff we talk about
around here every day and we have for 25
plus years and it's helped millions of
people because common sense is now so
uncommon that it is now marketable and
we make a pretty good living selling it
I'll just tell you but we're here to
help it's what we do we're gonna answer
your questions walk with you and courage
you we're gonna tell you the truth when
something stupid we're going to tell you
it's stupid when it's weird we're gonna
tell you it's weird if you're acting
crazy we're gonna tell you you know even
though there's crazy people nobody ever
tells them they're crazy
it's a refreshing thing when it occurs
so we had a guy stop in and I heard the
lobby one day he was just loopy I mean
he's just really mentally ill it was
really sad but he was doing all kinds of
stuff he was telling everybody was Jesus
and he had two eyes in the center of his
head and everything else were like dude
don't tell people that that's just crazy
he said it is kind of crazy and then I
said you know it's crazy you don't need
to tell people that nobody says that the
crazy people do they just tell them we
love you here we're gonna help you you
want to help you be better get better
even if you're already excellent we want
you to be even better we want to take
you to a better place it's what we do
here so we're glad you're listening
we're glad you're hanging out with us
but here's the thing normal and America
is broke 78% of Americans have too much
month left at the end of the money they
spend every thing they make and then
some every month that's eight out of ten
houses on your street or broke you ever
drive down a middle-class Street and
they got upper-class cars in the
driveway tells you there's a problem you
can just count the payments is what
you're doing you ever drive down a
upper-class Street and notice the
middle-class cars in the driveway I was
with a billionaire the other day
that's a thousand million that's a lot
it's driving a 20 year old Mercedes it
looked like crap
I'm like dude you need to get a car
really you got a billion dollars this is
freaking pitiful I like my car they
don't give me a hard time
give me peer pressure you're Dave Ramsey
I'm something dude you've got a billion
dollars get you a car this thing's awful
you know you don't want to reap one
otherwise you got a billion dollars he
didn't care what you think
didn't care what I think he threw by the
boy he's not gonna buy a car but you
ever notice that middle class people
Drive upper-class cars and wonder why
they're broke upper-class people drive
lower-class cars and they know why
they're not middle class anymore
interesting where will we live in we're
here to help you you jump in and we'll
talk hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]